có một công việc ở Google,
lực cao, lắp việc ở nước ngoài
khết cơ đến tuổi sợ ở Mỹ trong mở
And Jackie, Wooden, cháu về Việt Nam
để lặp cho một sợ áp
Đúng vào không tìa quá lớn tất cả mọi thứ họ làm
bui trên cách là mà nó quá tìm trận rõ
thì kế phòng mà làm được nơi xe hơi nhỏ
Mình vào Google vào khoảng 2-3 trên mình đã
nhưng nhận cái vị trí này nó hay
Nhẹ, sau đó không vị kỹ sơ của mình
trước bạn 2-3,
mình yêu gọi sinh ngập học
mình quan đợ được khoảng 2-3,
mình cảm thấy không quá
nghĩ khu rộn đỏ để về Việt Nam
và kết tận đẩn đúng đó là chào tốt
chỉ với 1 giúp viên bắt đầu
và có thể nói là chứ thành thình
sau với mức lần,
sinh ngập,
thì ở thấy nó mức lũ cho tốt
và nó đo khoảng 4-4 phần trận nó đo khoảng 3 phần trận đúng
thật,
thì các bạn đã có buổi không
có không ráng ở nước ngoài đi cơ mà người đây,
mình chế
trải qua nhiều vị trí
nhiều phay làm trái nhìn ngẹn
nhưng anh vẫn vương đến nhiều vị trí
vật li cấp cao
và chỉ kế cảo nhất yvr giám đốc được hành
nhưng cũng từ đây
anh đối dính với những thứ thách lần nhất sự nghiệp
tháng 6 năm nay
nhưng mà mình có tốt đẩn đẩn đúng
cái mạnh kinh dần của thủ mô
và mù bán ô tốt cậu
một cái gì an tăng mới khoảng 3 năm
thì ở đây nó 1 lắm,
bao nhiêu tăng mới
thì ở đây có chỉ mà kế u
phải nghiệp vẫn cơ,
tại sao những cái lâu vẫn mở bây
tên này,
bởi lại thích,
tại khó khèc
tôi mùa học sinh vinh mắt ở bên lòng
đến ký xíu hả dầu và sinh gấp dọc
từ chấu cả gú gộc
và các bạn bắt đầu từ số khong ở mục sát đáp
và gia đình là CEO cho tốt
anh quyền trong tất cả kì
cách mai ở tập này của The First app
Đó first step,
là nơi ký tổ sẽ trò chuyện với những người
dạm dễ phần,
lãng nghe lý cho họ khởi tạo
và cách bỏ trường đặt